I've been working in the space of ethnic
fairness we're talking about about
tracking and improving information the
service of fairness
okay great we are great so thank you
Katrina today I'm going to talk about
some joint work with soo mega guard at
Princeton and Omer my advisor which
studies fairness in prediction tasks
from an information theoretic
perspective
great so I know this is officially a
privacy workshop and so even though the
majority of my talk will center around
fairness yeah right so so at the end
I'll give some musings on how the the
our conclusions sort of interact with
privacy both differential privacy and
beyond I have a lot of slides and I
expect to get through a very small
fraction of them so please interrupt if
you have questions great so issues of
fairness and discrimination in
prediction systems have been getting a
lot of attention recently both in the
popular press as well as the academic
literature and so there have been many
explanations for why discrimination
maybe shows up in machine learning
models and there have been maybe even
more attempts to fix the problem but it
seems that with every attempt at fixing
the problem there somebody else comes
along and says your attempt is
completely broken here's why and we
should do something completely different
and frankly the state of affairs is
pretty overwhelming and confusing right
now and so in this work we're not going
to propose a new definition of fairness
but instead sort of try to take a step
back and say what's really going on here
what what are specific ways in which
many of the popular notions of fairness
can fail and then we'll try to give some
directives on how to fix such failures
and prevent them so at a high level our
setting will involve decision making
about individuals so individuals will
show up let's say for concreteness
they're showing up and they are applying
for a loan from a bank and so the first
thing that will happen is that these
individuals will be mapped into a space
of risk scores they'll be mapped to some
estimated probability of say the
probability that they'll repay the loan
if they're given one and we'll say
the predictor is what map's them to a
risk score and then based on this risk
score and possibly some auxilary
information the decision-maker or the
bank has to decide whether to has to
make a binary decision whether to give
them a loan or whether to reject their
application so that's our highest-level
setting so throughout the talk I'm going
to be using sort of these risk score
histograms and so they'll be useful for
understanding many of the issues going
on here so what what's going on in in
these plots so these histograms
represent the distribution of outputs
given by the predictor given sort of the
input distribution so in particular on
the x-axis I have a risk sore or an
estimated probability of repayment let's
say and on the Wyatt axis I have the
fraction of individuals from a given
population receiving that score so in
red or orange here I have one population
receiving a score of 0.5 and everybody
in the population is receiving it and in
the blue population I have different
scores so throughout I'm going to assume
that these predictions are so-called
calibrated so calibration has a formal
definition that hopefully I'll get to
later but you should think of
calibration is saying that the the
predictions mean what they say that is
to say that for example amongst the
individuals who are receiving score 0.5
about half of them will actually in
reality repay their loans and about half
of them will default so I'll pause there
is sort of the these plots will be
important so if there's any confusion
about what's going on in these plots
please stop me
so this is this doesn't affect reality
outside yeah right so good so we'll
think about one time step for now and
but there there has been other work
talking about sort of longer term of
effects and we'll discuss some of them
here no so I'm I'm assuming that the
prediction is something that let's go
back so I'm assuming that the prediction
is the output of an algorithm so that
that is factual it's the output it
doesn't mean that it represents reality
very faithfully I'm making a mild
assumption about the degree to which it
represents reality
we'll see sort of the I'll spoil the
main point that that yes assuming that
the that these predictions are fact can
be incredibly problematic and sort of
that that is one of the the points of
one of the conclusions and so we'll
discuss the ways in which sort of the
informativeness of these predictions
actually impacts the long-term decision
makers so so what I mean is that sort of
when the prediction says 0.5 about half
of the people who receive that score
actually will repay and will not repay
so no it's it's a subtle distinction so
alternatively I could take these 0.5
people and potentially maybe maybe it
isn't uniform across the group that they
all have a 50% chance maybe there are
half of the people really are very
clearly going to repay and half are
really clearly going to not repay so
that is the distinction between reality
and the prediction
also if it helps think about the
algorithm outputting things that are
numbers
these people are Apple these people are
banana and then you just look at the
population and say oh for 40% of the
Apple people are you know repay the
loans and then just change the name
Apple to point four and we'll see this
issue it's gonna show up on the next
slide yes let's assume for the sake of
argument that today that the the
predictor is a deterministic map from
inputs to to outputs and the probability
that I'm taking is just over the
population distribution so okay at a
sort of a bird's eye view abstractly
what we would love to do is ensure that
the decision-maker treats all groups in
our population fairly and so we'll see
on the next few slides that even
understanding what that means is very
complicated and much trickier than then
it might sound and and it's difficult
and we don't have good answers for that
yet but so for for this warm up example
I want to simplify things a ton I want
to assume that that there's two sets of
people in the world there are the
graduate students and there are the tech
workers SMT and I want to make sure that
I'm treating these two groups fairly and
further I'm going to assume again for
the sake of simplicity that these
populations in their ability to repay
loans are incredibly similar they're
identically distributed and in both
populations about half the people will
repay their loans and about half of them
will default so that is to say that the
probability of y equals 1 equals 0.5 in
both populations
that's the reality so where am I going
to complicate things I'm going to
complicate things in these predictions
exactly this issue that we were
discussing so I I required that the
predictions are calibrated but I didn't
say anything more than that so let's
let's look at these two populations in s
I'm going to assume that there's a
constant prediction that just gives out
the sort of mean probability the average
probability across the entire group and
so again amongst the individuals who
receive this score point five about half
of them will repay and half of them will
default so that satisfies our notion of
calibration
however this score gives us no
information that we didn't already know
about this about an individual so when I
see an individual score I learned
nothing more than I did then just
knowing that they were in s already and
in T I'm going to assume that there is
some variability that actually there is
some signal so in T I'll say that
basically half the people get score 0.75
half get score 0.25 and again because
I've assumed calibration this means that
these distinctions really represent true
signal
I actually know that if somebody is in
this group on average at least they have
a higher likelihood of repaying their
loan so is the setup clear I'm
simplifying things greatly but we'll see
that it still results in some
interesting issues absolutely know so I
I think this is a great point that that
sort of this is sort of taken to the
extreme but I think it's a very
reasonable assumption that in practice
and people have sort of pointed to this
as a source of discrimination in these
systems that somehow you are not
adequately modeling different
populations and that
that the features or that your
computational resources that you're
investing into making predictions about
these populations are not adequately you
know similar we're expressive good so
the one of the first approaches you
might think would achieve a certain
notion of fairness would be to set a
group independent threshold or a group
independent decision-making policy so
this would try to aim at getting at some
sort of meritocratic fairness we're
ideally individuals would be sort of
selected or not selected similarly based
on their similarity in their ability to
repay the loan right but we'll see that
sort of when you use predicted risk
scores the best you can hope for is that
the that you select individuals
similarly based on their prediction and
this can lead to issues so for instance
suppose the bank is willing to accept
and give out a loan if there's at least
a 60% chance that that individuals will
repay so that means they're gonna set a
sort of fixed threshold at about point 6
and lo and behold in this example this
leads to the fact that only individuals
from this group t will be selected and
why is why is that because no one in S
received a score greater than 0.6 and
this occurs even though remember that we
assumed that these populations were
distributed identically so these
populations are very similar in their
ability to repay loans yet we're seeing
huge disparities in the selection rates
about half of the individuals in T are
selected and none are selected in S and
so from the perspective of these
populations being similarly distributed
this seems blatantly unfair so maybe we
have to go back to the drawing board and
so a very different approach to fairness
that has been studied extensively is the
notion of so-called demographic or
statistical parity
yes it seems like you're not allowing
yourself to say that the predictor
algorithm is the thing that's unfair it
seems like you yeah yeah I will allow
myself to say that in about three slides
yeah yeah but but others have not
allowed themselves to say that that's
far right so so good so good so so this
notion of demographic parity or
statistical parity aims to equalize the
selection rates and it's one of the sort
of main well studied notions of parity
in selection there there's many others
but this is a simple one to start so in
particular will require that explicitly
that our selection rule selects the same
fraction of people in both populations
so suppose again that the bank sets us
suppose that T is sort of the majority
population they're going to dominate the
the utility or the the revenue for the
bank and so the the bank will set a
threshold accordingly in for this
population T let's say again they set a
threshold at about point six so this
means that they've selected half of the
population of T and these individuals
have about a 75% chance of repaying
their loans again because we've set our
selection rate to be 0.5 that means we
have to select half of the individuals
in s but again we have no information
about S right our score has told us
nothing about who are the individuals
likely or unlikely to repay their loans
so at best
the bank can select a random subset of
the population s and so what does this
mean this leads to big differences in a
number of key quantities that people in
the fairness and just prediction
literature would like to track the true
positive rate the false positive rate
the positive predictive value if you
don't know what these terms mean it's
not too important but basically these
are all indicators of the quality of
your selection rule
and basically all of these quantities
are better in tea than in s another
issue is that the utility decreases for
the lender the bank isn't going to be
very happy if you tell them that they
have to take a huge hit and further some
recent work by LeWitt all has actually
argued that this type of selection
policy can cause further harm to the
minority populations that this sort of
parody notion is designed to protect and
this gets back to the idea of sort of
things being in a feedback loop in
particular the argument goes at a high
level that as you push this selection
threshold down in the minority
population you end up selecting people
who have a higher risk of defaulting
which increases the default rate which
then makes the bank less likely to want
to lend to them in the future and so
issues of sort of these delayed impact
and feedback loops are huge and but
already we see that there's issues in a
single time step good so any questions
at this point yeah so I'm sorry yeah I
don't understand the question and then
risks together and then distributed
risks across society in a way I need to
offset so the bank actually would be
indifferent the bank would just say
interest rates are going to be slightly
higher to account for the worse
but so I'm not I you're speaking a
slightly different language than the one
that I speak but I think if I if I can
guess the the point would be that the
interest rates would be less desirable
in the population s than in T and and
and this is a consequence not of s's
inherent ability to repay their loans
but a consequence of your sub-optimal
reflection of reality in your
predictions is paying higher interest
rates okay okay
better or worse s is paying worse is
getting worse treatment I can't to met I
cannot imagine that would actually be
paying the price why because t would
otherwise the bank would always lend to
t if lower interest rates now the bank
is to love the s the losses in s on T so
I think I understand right I I think I
understand let's take it offline but I
guess the point the point that I would
make is that if we're viewing the the
job of the bank as estimating risk
somehow somebody is paying the burden
for their inability to distinguish in S
and so the question is sort of what what
happens if we improve things
Roka okay
so thus far the the fairness on sorry
the literature in fairness has resisted
some sort of universal definition of
fairness and we can argue about sort of
the the universality of differential
privacy but at least in in some very
specific contexts differential privacy
provides a really strong and really
compelling notion of privacy protections
and thus far sort of most if not all of
the notions presented in the fairness
literature have some issues that people
have pointed to that feel insurmountable
and sort of a lot of the critiques end
up saying something along the lines that
under your fairness constraints you end
up selecting the wrong set of
individuals and so I want to pause
though and and sort of go to Bo's point
that like let's imagine a case where we
actually had perfect predictions where
we had great information about all of
our population well under perfect
predictions you know this has been
observed in a lot of the literature
actually that many issues disappear so
for instance an hour you know very toy
example in this talk basically notions
of group independent threshold in and
demographic parity will do exactly the
same thing in this scenario where the
two populations are identically
distributed and you have perfect
information about them and so the
question then sort of is to ask what
about better predictions for some notion
of better does that buy you anything and
so the main result in our paper that
I'll present as a theorem in quotes here
is that basically improving information
content for a specific notion of
information content in your predictions
actually improves the downstream fair
selection role across a wide collection
of sort of quantities that
both the bank and the individuals would
care about and so one way to interpret
our theorem is to say that at times the
perceived cost of fairness is really not
a cost due to the fairness desiderata
that you've stated as much as due to an
information disparity across populations
if you had good information about all of
your populations then the cost would be
offset that there wouldn't really be a
cost to enforcing these firms goals and
another takeaway is that getting your
hands on highly informative calibrated
predictions is important even if the
goal of sort of fairness at the end of
the day is parity based and so right
this sort of this interpretation pushes
back against one of the main notions or
a concept that has been sort of stated
in my opinion overstated in the fairness
literature that says like accuracy and
parody are inherently at odds I want to
like basically replace that thought in
your mind with sort of refined
predictions that allow for improved sort
of more information give you improved
utility impact disparity which all have
formal definitions that I didn't so some
takeaways I think as we've sort of
discussed information disparity can
arise in across populations for many
different reasons and it's important
when you have a risk score predictor to
audit these scores for their information
content in our paper we give some sort
of formal tools for doing this
I'll speak at a high level here but but
sort of concretely it would be
interesting to look at say credit scores
that are used in practice and understand
sort of can you demonstrate that
empirically the risk scores in some
populations are less informative than in
others
and if so then that means you need to
either invest more computational effort
or or collect better features then
another key takeaway is for us as
researchers when we're designing and
critiquing fairness notions we need to
ask ourselves what set of assumptions
does my notion explicitly or implicitly
make fallen has a great paper sort of
making this point very clear that like
every notion of fairness makes some
underlying assumptions about your
populations what are they and let's
state them more clearly let's state them
explicitly upfront so that we can reason
about them the next point is sort of
that a question to ask is are my
requirements for fairness robust in a
certain sense to information disparity
that is to say that sort of when you're
stating a fairness visit or autumn-like
make sure it's exactly what you mean and
one once you have that goal like let's
say it you know it's to increase
representation in the minority
population that's not the same thing as
mathematically as saying I want
statistical Perry right so let's make
sure that we faithfully translate these
sort of notions into mathematical
constraints and understand what the
consequence of requiring these
constraints would be if we have less
information in one population versus
another and then finally I think it's
important to ask ourselves when we're
critiquing notions when we come up with
something that we don't like about a
fairness notion ask ourselves am i
exploiting sort of the true sort of
principled approach to fairness here or
am i exploiting disparity in information
across my population and it's sort of
it's important to understand you know
yeah I'm not saying that exploiting
information disparity isn't a reasonable
thing to do just saying to disambiguate
these these things and and critique what
you really mean to critique yeah
you're using information as the like the
key concept here and it's it feels like
what you're using it like you could
replace accuracy kind of everywhere in
this slide so uh yeah so so formally I
didn't have time to talk about this and
I tailored this talk to be more
high-level but what I mean by
information has a formal definition in
the context of calibrated predictors and
it is closely tied to let's say squared
error or or or yeah or likelihood or
some variance exactly yeah I think the
distinction is that that it's important
to reason about these things with
calibration and this notion once you
spend you know fix things to be
calibrated then these notions of like
accuracy with respect to say squared
error variance these kinds of things and
information are basically equivalent so
like yes accuracy and information are
sort of the same thing here
is the information that you need great
question so so yes absolutely so when I
say information like I'm I'm saying sort
of your ability to make reasonable
predictions about the population that
you haven't observed if I can do if
there is a simple rule or if there is
maybe not even a simple rule if there is
a rule for you know predicting Y given X
that I can learn from the population
then largely I should be able to do this
in a differentially private manner I
should be able to collect aggregate
statistics and
you know incorporate these statistics
into my predictions you know and we even
do this in the paper and and in another
paper we show that it's compatible with
differential privacy it's not too hard
to see so in in a sense this does give
you a way to sort of have you know learn
simultaneously fair and private
predictions but then sort of to say
something maybe a little bit more
controversial in this beyond
differential privacy workshop I think a
question to ask yourself is sort of is
the notion of differential privacy what
we what we really want here I've been
arguing that your ability to make
predictions across populations very
accurately or you know informatively is
essential to fairness but maybe that
means collecting more data maybe that
means you know me being able to make a
prediction about you even if I've never
seen you before and is that a solution
that we you know feel comfortable with
and so I think think you know thinking
about information is important here
who's using the information what are
they using it for
and for people who know more about this
than me I would love to hear your
thoughts if contextual integrity or
something along these lines makes sense
here so I'll stop there
for now and take any questions
yeah it's a great just too big so like
one is that there's like a pretty well
thought through like a trade-off between
fairness in the sense of not
discrimination and privacy so that's an
excellent paper from like maybe ten
years ago that makes us exact point
rifles like the way you could solve this
type of problem is by going off to
collect more information but that itself
then raises privacy concerns and I'll be
happy to share that and that's
economists have thought about this as
well yeah I was gonna ask those like I'm
with a legal perspective what's often
interested mean it's something that
Jamie maybe with the first person to
bring to my attention what is that an
argument against doing this like
spending money to go collect additional
features is cost and sometimes you can
actually justify like the fact that your
decision-making process results in
discrimination by saying that the
additional cost that I would incur to
collect necessary informative features
is so substantial that it's like
impractical and there's actually like
cases that are decided about this right
like we can't compel people to take on
some burden that would basically run the
business into the ground right so I'm
kind of interested how some of this work
also my feed into like legal arguments
about like well can we sort of think
about the degree to which we want to say
no actually you have to incur this cost
or like this is such a ridiculous kind
of like uneven way of making decisions
that like even if you know the cost is
substantial like we're gonna still or
assert that you do this and I actually
think JP be the most interesting point
which is that she was pointing out to me
at this event like if costs ends up
being dissipation for not doing this
like the decision-maker gets to set the
baseline by just choosing some have we
got bad decision-making process in the
first place and saying it's expensive to
do something better
like I guess I don't know the formal
trade-off in terms of expense because I
don't understand a lot particularly well
but it is interesting a little bit
there's this one up like you make
reference to what is common practice
among your peers right so if like
everyone else in your industry is doing
this even though like that means there's
like manifest disparate impact or
something that's okay right in that
everybody to example of this is like we
have like 10 credit files are
credit-invisible people like what we
just don't have very much information
and like that clearly has a disparate
impact right if the people who are not
well represented and writing files tend
to be disproportionately members of
protected classes and we still say like
that's okay we're not going to force the
people to go spend money to collect
information and somehow that's
reasonable because that's common
practice across the industry yeah I
think what's interesting here is that
this notion of information it's
something that we've given a little bit
of thought to not from the same
perspective but but this notion of
information is something that like the
bank would benefit from anyway right
like like I'm saying like if if I gave
this to you for free
you you know and you got to predict for
the future forever and ever like it
would be in your interest to have this
information if you know yeah I'm saying
so so like you know I can argue formally
that that sort of if this information
were given to you for free you should
take it and you can always simulate the
decisions that you wanted you know that
you had without this information even if
you're given the information I can throw
it out so so it can't hurt you and so
the question is sort of I mean I think
it's a super interesting point and it's
one that we've thought about from you
know theoretical computer science
perspective but not further
correct we shouldn't allow
personalization be on some level of
information so you know such a moment
the moment you open your computer any
computer we know very little about you
and immediately start personalizing to
you and this word or other approaches
can be very can create value and we can
say we can ever with Mesa saying that if
you're informativeness on sensitive no
some pressure some fixed pressure and
from civilizations who just not be
allowed because some addition at that
point of not knowing is just being based
on just definition of discrimination
finish and stereotypes right explanation
based on very good information is a
therapy right I think our point was just
that like it's interesting to think
about this in terms of like the legal
arguments that come from information
never being free yeah do you answer the
question cuz I'm just gonna make an
announcement maybe a question is unfair
definition Bernie but about the relation
between whiskey trust so you assume that
risk is embodied in the score is somehow
neutral
so you assume that the group's the
distribution of the ability to return
alone is exogenous in the sense that
that's we don't ask her any questions
about that this is just given by the
market nature society some exogenous and
part of the problem so if we shift from
the market to health just to give an
example right we would not necessarily
say that people with higher risks or
some diseases which is genetic through
therefore necessarily pay any higher
insurance we will say when maybe we're
not gonna ask this right but cuz we
don't trust right because we think that
there may be some economic reasons why
the HMOs are their insurance will say
well we do want to tax you for your
genetic disease so we're gonna don't we
want to reach a higher more efficient
way and that would mean that if you were
born a certain way then life is just
going to be more expensive with it stuff
like that's nature sorry really somehow
would think I think that this is an
unfair this is unfair because of the
distribution of this so to the extent
that you include distribution of risks
indulgently in the model i think you
might get a different result with
respect to to information it's a it's a
it's an interesting point right so I
think our assumptions or you know the
work lies at a level of the abstraction
that isn't modeling these kinds of
concerns and it is sort of assuming a
trustworthy decision-maker who's doing
things in the best interests but we we
should talk about it offline yeah there
are many more questions to be raised but
yeah let's looking out to it so they're
gonna be co-located more chops for lack
of a better word right now it's not just
workshops with ACF at
coming here and we're basically it's
called critiquing and be visiting all
the subcraft
and this would be like a perfect
workshop to bring in people from
different backgrounds who want to look
at this budget and criticize